[Musique]
comment tu as pu te retrouver dans cette
école pour voleurs tu vas entendre toute
l'histoire
bienvenue à l'école de zain l'institut
de formation pour voleurs de haut rang
si tu choisis la voie des voleurs
professionnels
il te sera impossible de revenir en
arrière
tu es la voleuse la plus douée de toute
la classe volet n'est pas un jeu quand
on vole on blesse des gens surtout si
c'est leur vie qu'on a l'intention de
voler qui tue vraiment tu peux m'appeler
carmel
des agents de veille subtilité oeuvre à
travers le monde les faits comment
l'équateur si tout se passe bien
j'aurais déjà mis tous ses trésors en
sécurité avant que paul ne mette la main
dessus
les
peut-être que pour une raison qui
m'échappe carmen sandiego est une
voleuse qui ne volent qu'à d'autres
voleurs
et maintenant que la fête commence pour
rien le tirera vers le barp
je me laisserai plus faire
[Musique]
arrêtez vous immédiatement vous n'avez
pas dit combien de temps
mais où se cache ton carmen san diego
tu mets ton manteau par cette chaleur
j'ai besoin de mes jouets
[Musique]